[Música]
os presento a mi amigo frank mi amigo
frank no está aquí es es un ser
imaginario pero mi amigo frank vive con
nosotros en cualquier parte del mundo
podría ser cualquier sitio en cualquier
ciudad en cualquier país
frank trabaja en una explotación
agrícola se dedica junto con sus padres
a cultivar la tierra y específicamente a
los frutales
y bueno pues la marca quizás de esa
explotación agrícola son los melocotones
1 melocotones naranjas con un sabor a
miel que no los hay en ninguna otra
parte del mundo sin embargo al conseguir
uno de estos melocotones implica un
trabajo arduo en la finca frank que ha
estudiado derecho en una universidad
online y conoce las normas sabe cómo
contratar a los jornaleros que trabajan
en la finca casi todos eventuales conoce
las duras condiciones de vida y de
trabajo de estos jornaleros
sabe perfectamente las obligaciones
legales los tiene que hacer un contrato
de trabajo tiene que darlos de alta en
seguridad social hay que retener parte
de lo que se les paga y hay que pagarles
una cantidad que está garantizada por
ley o por convenio colectivo y esa esa
parte de salario no puede bajar de diez
euros a la hora frank pensaba que ese
sueldo está perfectamente adecuado a
esas duras condiciones donde además
frank y su familia tenía que procurarles
unas condiciones de seguridad de
prevención de riesgos laborales los
riesgos eran máximos y riesgos
climatológicos caídas atrapamientos
reglamentos incluso algunas ocasiones se
sentían bastante incómodos porque tenían
que prescindir de los servicios de
algunos de los trabajador de la finca
y bueno pues como todos sabéis el
despido implica también una cantidad de
dinero cansado de esta falta de
equilibrio entre ese melocotón que tanto
valora frank y esas condiciones de
trabajo deciden marchar a la ciudad
frank marcha la ciudad porque quiere
socializar pero la mejor forma de
socializar hoy en día cuál es pues a
través del smartphone claro se da de
alta en todas las redes sociales y él
quiere ser autónomo
pero autónomo no del régimen de
seguridad social como ya lo era en la
finca quiere ser autónomo para vivir
quiere quiere mantener un nivel de vida
independiente de sus padres y va a la
ciudad claro cómo va a la ciudad pues a
través de plataformas digitales que
permiten compartir el vehículo un señor
que pasa por ahí y le lleva a la ciudad
comparten los gastos no conocéis todos
este tipo de plataformas no vamos a dar
nombres vamos a intentar no dar los no
bueno pues por un módico precio frank
llega a la ciudad compartiendo esos
gastos con esa persona que amablemente
le lleva en el coche una vez que está en
la ciudad incluso se puede desplazar en
lugar de por un taxi pues a través del
móvil pues bueno pues por todas estas
agencias de transporte que transportan
personas y bueno pues que realmente sale
un precio bastante barato claro frank
dicen que voy a trabajar a mí me gusta
esto
bueno pues para trabajar en una agencia
de estas necesita un vehículo propio y
se da cuenta de que se tiene que dar el
de alta en autónomos lo cual le supone
un coste
claro no tiene coche no tiene vehículo
que otras formas hay en la ciudad hay
unos jinetes que se llaman riders
en bicicleta pues transportan mercancías
o comida de restaurantes hacia los
clientes y bueno pues mira para una
bicicleta pues si me llega no cuánto
puedo sacar ahí
bueno pues puede sacar más o menos al
día entre cinco euros diez euros según
las horas claro y cuántas horas el
problema las que quieras
es el trabajo es el trabajo en la
plataforma digital no hay límites en
nada no se aplican normas de nada no te
preocupes no tienes que darte de alta en
seguridad social no tienes que pagar
impuestos
esto esto es toda la bomba
pero claro saco entre cinco y diez euros
al día voy a buscar más plataformas
digitales y nuestro amigo frank pues
encuentra cosas bueno pues lo que antes
eran trabajos amistosos benévolos de
buena voluntad lo que era dar clase y
cuidar niños sacar al perro hay
plataformas para sacar al perro incluso
para llevarte al perro a casa
cuánto puedes ganar bueno realmente esta
se de una actividad profesional porque
le estás haciendo todas las horas del
día no hay límite de horas puedes
trabajar 20 horas que no pasa nada no
hay convenio colectivo aplicable no hay
límites nena
claro frank dice bueno cuanto voy a
poder sacar bueno pues puedo sacar otra
vez entre cinco euros y diez euros al
día hay plataformas de lo de lo más
extraño se pueden hacer traducciones a
través de internet a través de esa
plataforma que conecta al cliente con el
prestador de servicios bueno pues te
pagan una cantidad grado si esa cantidad
que te pagan resulta que no eres bien
valorado en el trabajo pues es la última
el último punto que percibes porque te
excluyen de esa plataforma
claro que sí que me puedo ir a otras y
ahí llegamos a las verdaderas
plataformas reinas digitales donde ya no
conectan al prestador de servicios para
que preste físicamente un servicio no es
trabajo digital puro no voy a decir los
nombres pero se pueden encontrar son
macro empresas internacionales muy
conocidas
donde se realizan lo que se denominan
micro tareas es decir las las micro task
por qué porque un cliente grande
encomienda una tarea muy grande a esa
plataforma para que esa plataforma la
divida en trocitos pequeñitos que los
puede repartir en un día a miles a
decenas de miles de trabajadores con el
resultado de que en un día tiene toda la
actividad hecha que actividades son esas
fundamentalmente de marketing digital
etiquetado análisis de encuestas el
visionado de los vídeos para ver si
tienen contenido ya sabéis
erótico-festivo o de cualquier otro tema
violento etcétera claro que eso lo ven
estos se trabajadores estos ser
trabajadores de estas plataformas
digitales vienen a cobrar por cada tarea
un salario que está entre los 0 y los 2
dólares se pagan dólares y cómo se paga
se paga por banco pues en muchos casos
no en muchos casos ni siquiera se paga
con dinero
claro frank se da cuenta de que con ese
dinero que obtiene trabajando en esas
plataformas tiene la oportunidad porque
se acuerda de ese melocotón de comprar
un melocotón de la finca de su padre
porque ahora los venden por internet
sabéis cuál es el precio de ese
melocotón de la finca de su padre cinco
euros
es decir el dinero que podía ganar él
imaginaros los lagrimones de nuestro
amigo frank verdad
claro
el problema es que yo soy el abogado de
mi amigo frank
realmente es es mi amigo y es mi cliente
y mi amigo frank me dice me han excluido
de una de estas macro plataformas
yo creo que estos son despiden
procedente
pero vamos a ver cómo vas a tener un
despido improcedente tú tienes contrato
no tú conoces a tu empleador quién es tu
empresario
al loro la contestación
mi jefe es un algoritmo perdona pero tú
no has tratado con nadie de carne y
hueso no no quién me asigna los trabajos
es un algoritmo quien me paga es un
algoritmo yo no sé ni quién es mi
cliente
mi cliente me valora no me gustas y me
echan de la plataforma y yo creo que el
cliente no tiene razón bueno no pasa
nada para eso tenemos la tutela judicial
efectiva
donde demandó a quien demandó dónde está
esa empresa está en españa está en reino
unido está en eeuu que reclamó cuál es
el salario mínimo que tiene que percibir
ese trabajador dónde están los logros
que ha conseguido la humanidad el mundo
del trabajo el derecho del trabajo a
finales del siglo 19 el siglo 20 en 1873
había ya una ley que prohibía el trabajo
de menores en 1904 el área del descanso
dominical en 1912 la ley de la silla que
permitía a las mujeres trabajar sentadas
en 1919 el retiro obrero primer régimen
de seguridad social y las pensiones que
pensión va a tener mi amigo frank pero
si no ha cotizado en su vida
toda esta actividad económica tiene
algún reflejo en positivo que puedan
percibir los estados tampoco esa
supranacionalidad impide que se apliquen
las normas territoriales con lo cual yo
que soy el abogado de mayo frank pues
mira es que es que no sé realmente web
estar un amigo frank me dice bueno y
como te pago como quieres que te pague
bueno tú me has conectado por una
plataforma no
pues te voy a cobrar en especie un
melocotón de la finca de tu padre
bueno pues perdonarme pero mi amigo fran
meric alma otra vez a través de la
plataforma muchas gracias
[Aplausos]